-Welcome back, everybody.
This is really happening.
I'm here with Miley Cyrus,
and she is going --
[ Cheers and applause ]
She is going to shave my beard
right now on live television.
We're going to do this.
-Yep.
This promotional plan
I have going,
this is definitely going to make
everyone watch
my New Year's show.
-Yeah, when you think about --
-This is going to help.
-This is live. This is exactly
what's going to happen
New Year's. You're going to
shave people's beard.
-I do this for Dolly
all the time.
-Have you? [ Laughs ]
-Have you ever shaved
anyone's beard before?
-No. I don't know what's
going to --
I don't know
what you're going to look like.
-Okay.
-Ready?
-Yup.
-Okay.
-Ah. Ooh, this feels nice.
[ Laughs ]
-Hey, very professional.
-Yeah. This is good.
All right.
-Alright, you're sure
about this?
-Yeah. Oh, you gotta --
Oh, it's a reveal.
-We have to reveal.
-Oh, I gotcha. I understand.
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience shouts ]
-My God. Why did I --
-Never. Never.
-Alright, ready?
-Yeah.
-Should I go up?
-I don't know.
-Okay.
[ Audience gasping ]
-Is it coming off?
-Yeah.
-Do you guys want to
see this?
[ Audience cheers ]
-Okay, hold on, hold on.
You can't rush perfection.
-That's true.
-Okay.
Well, okay.
-All right. Can I --
-It's not as bad as it looks.
You're a little bloody.
No, you look great.
Look how good you look.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Okay.
We have to make it even.
-Okay. Is it coming off?
-It wouldn't hurt me to get
the ears.
-Is it coming off easy?
-There you go -- yeah.
-Kind of looks fun.
Oh, you gave me a goatee.
This feels pretty good.
I feel like a wrestler.
-All right. What about this?
-Yeah. I like it.
-What do you think about it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah! I'll see you in the ring!
I'll see you in the ring,
brother!
You see there?
You better be there.
New Year's Eve --
[ Speaking gibberish ]
I swear it --
-No.
Okay.
This part's a little tricky.
-That part is kind
of gross part --
-It just seems -- Yeah.
-There's a lot of beard there.
-Oh, my God.
I think it's in my mouth.
-[ Laughs ] It's not.
It did not.
You just threw a chunk
on the ground.
I heard it fall.
[ Light laughter ]
-Okay. Now you've got, like,
a little --
I don't even know what.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Oh, I see.
-Okay, wait.
[ Laughter ]
-No --
-Sorry.
Oh, yeah, this part,
I gotta go --
Okay.
Hold on.
Oh, yeah.
I'm supposed to go like this.
Wait, this part --
Oh, God, sorry.
-It just went up my nose.
[ Cymbal clashes ]
-How's it looking?
You look great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I look like the "time to
make the donuts" guy.
I think this is a good start
right here.
-You look great.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I think this is it
right here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Why is it up there?
-I don't know, it went
everywhere, all over the place.
This is how you do it
right here.
Miley Cyrus knows how to do it.
Thank you for doing this.
-You look great.
-You're the best. Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Miley Cyrus, everybody.
She's hosting
"Miley's New Year's Eve Party,"
airing live on NBC and Peacock,
December 31st at 10:30 P.M.
We'll be right back
with Jesse Williams.
[ Cheers and applause ]